okay guys this is part two of my Twitter
Q&A at Rubin report on the Twitter I ask
you guys if you any questions for me and
here we go number 1 million de Bennett
what's your favourite lightsabre color
very controversial question there Millie
uh uh you know what I'm gonna say purple
uh mace windu was the only Jedi that I
know of that had the purple lightsaber
I'd like to know a little bit more about
the purple I'd say you know we know that
the Luke had green we know Darth Vader
had read okay standard stuff uh but what
what was going on with mace windu it is
what lightsaber he I believe according
Star Wars lore was the was the best
sword fighter so what was going on with
the purple lightsaber I'd like to know
I'm sure it's in the expanded universe
somewhere if you guys know please let me
know okay what's next buick 59 why
aren't the media sentinels of democracy
anymore why is fox news lentil I by the
news are the cokes buying the senate uh
i mean again this is this is one of our
wheelhouse things and this is why online
media is so important uh y-you look the
media has failed the media they go to
parties with the same people they're
supposed to be reporting on all the time
they have we're doing a story on my show
today that we're about to tape shortly
about how right before obama gave his
big Isis speech last week he had an
off-the-record meeting with tons of
journalists from major publications so
that they could get the messaging across
before he even gave the speech and then
they'd be you know they do the White
House Correspondents Dinner they're
going to birthday parties you know Obama
was at Alex Witt who is MSNBC host got
married to the White House chef and
Obama's at the wedding there isn't
anything inherently wrong with all of
that but it all adds up to something
that kind of stinks because then look if
you ask shitty questions in the White
House press briefing room there's an you
know just easy question softball
questions there's a better chance that
you're gonna get moved up to the front
and ask the question again you know who
decides what questions are going to be
asked and who's gonna when obama's gonna
pick them someone's decided because they
know the questions in advance so we
really don't have a truly independent
media anymore and that's why the online
thing is so important and i hope we're
giving you like just a tiny bit of a
taste of what should
Debbie going on what's next Mike Regin
madam uh you ever [ __ ] in your pants as
an adult uh good question uh about 10
years ago i had just started going to
just started working out uh and i was
taking creatine which is like uh some
kind of i'm supposed to do something for
your muscles take a little creatine and
uh you know it makes your stomach nuts
and it's a lot of water i think your
hold a lot of water and i was guy got
out of the subway i called man i gotta
go in my apartment was about four blocks
away from the subway and uh I ran I mean
I would really I did everything I could
do there was it a tiny skidmark ok
what's next uh benicar Braeden are you
not the rich gay one uh I'm not exactly
sure what you're referring to but I
assure you I'm not the rich one what's
next uh 36 accounting do you ever plan
on running for office like Al Franken
entertainer turned politician well some
would wonder whether I'm an entertainer
not but uh you know originally I was a
political science major in college I've
talked about that before and uh and I
wanted to be a politician that was my
original plan and then I kept taking all
these classes in all the classes they
just kept teaching us how bus did the
system is and how screwed up it is a
money in politics and all that now
certainly over the last you know 15
years or so that I've been at a college
I clearly see that um so I think my
place is maybe to be on the outside and
and comment on what's going on on the
inside I don't think I could do the
schmoozing I really don't like go there
and and be and shake hands with all
these people and feel like I'm beholdin
to all these people and all that uh
right now not really beholdin to anyone
and and that's why I can speak what's on
my mind so that's what I like doing
what's next Marcy 27 where do you
officially stand on the alien vs
predator debacle uh you know so predator
the original predator wish Schwartz in a
guy is one of my favorite action movies
of all time absolutely love it i
interview jesse ventura who is in that
movie who had that amazing gun you guys
probably remember that
that was a great great great great movie
even predator 2 with danny glover and
Gary Busey pretty good about a future in
LA that all hell's breakin was pretty
good and then of course the alien movies
with Sigourney at least the first two
were just fantastic and then they
combine them those they had two alien vs
predator uh combo movies and they were
just freaking awful unfortunately you
when you have a predator that can't
speak in an alien that can speak it
makes it hard for the dialogue of the
films uh so they're just kind of shitty
I hope they can figure out a way to get
them either back together the the
predator reboot from a couple years ago
with what's-his-name with that guy he
was in King Kong anyone anyone Adrien
Brody uh that was pretty good so you
know hopefully something else oh come
back what's next uh warlock any where do
babies come from uh Kenny google just uh
just google it and you know i think
you'll you'll find out it's pretty it's
pretty scary I'll admit that all right
that's it guys thank you for asking me
the questions we'll do it again in a
couple weeks Reuben report on Twitter
and keep watching and subscribing blah
blah blah blah blah ok